The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Erik and I
have been tag teaming
this lecture in this class
so we're going to
split this lecture.
So I get to do the
first 2 minutes.
No.
I get to do the first
20 minutes, or so,
talking about some
of my research
in parallel architecture.
And Erik's going to talk
about a bunch of things
that he's been up to over
the years in Algorithm Design
and Analysis.
So let's get started.
When was the first
PC built, anybody?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In the 1950s.
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS: No.
The first personal computer was
1981-- not the first computer.
So all of you know about
Intel, and Microsoft, and IBM,
and so on.
Intel's gift to humankind
is the x86 architecture.
Though, some people
would argue that point.
And the x86 architecture
was invented in 1981,
and was part of the first PC--
that provided the horsepower
for the first PC-- the IBM PC.
And it ran at 5 megahertz.
And x86 has been around-- you
still can buy x86 computers.
The 80486, in 1989,
ran at 25 megahertz.
So you can see a trend here.
And the 80486, as it
turns out, ended up
being called the I486 because
there was a court ruling that
said that you couldn't
trademark numbers.
And so Intel, at
that point, decided
to start naming
their processors.
So the Pentium, which is
one of the more famous Intel
processors, was built
and came out in 1993.
And the clock speed
went up to 66 megahertz,
back in the early '90s.
And since this is
just such a cool name,
Intel continued to call
its processors Pentium.
And the Pentium 4, in 2000, had
this incredibly deep pipeline
where you broke
up the computation
into a bunch of stages.
In fact, it had a
30 stage pipeline.
And so the clock speed went up
all the way to 1.5 gigahertz.
The Pentium was famous
for many things,
including a couple of
bugs in the floating point
pipeline where division,
in particular corner cases,
wasn't done correctly.
And there was also this bug
called the F00F bug, which
allowed a malicious program
to crash the entire system,
regardless of whether it had
administrative privileges
or not.
But the Pentium was
obviously very successful.
A lot of machines sold.
And it felt like it was only
going to be a matter of time
before we got to
10s of gigahertz,
the way things were going.
As you can see, this is
a pretty steep growth
from 5 megahertz to
25 to 1.5 gigahertz
in the space of about 20 years.
As it turns out, after the
Pentium D, which came out
in 2005, where the clock speed
peaked at about 3.2 gigahertz,
clock frequency
stopped increasing.
And what you see
now are things that
correspond to multiple
processors on a chip.
So for example, the Quad
Core Xeon came out in 2008.
You can still buy it.
Only runs at 3 gigahertz,
which is basically
about the same as
the Pentium D ran.
Each of these has a
range of frequencies.
And beyond about
2005, the clock speed
of processors that
you can buy is kind of
saturated at about 3 gigahertz.
And the way you're
getting performance
is by putting multiple
processors on the chip.
And people use the term cores
synonymously with processors.
So a quad core means
that they're, in effect,
four x86 processors on the same
silicon integrated circuit.
And they're
interconnected together.
And they talk to memory.
And you have, essentially,
a parallel processor
on a single chip.
And the single user, potentially
running many programs,
is using this system.
And you have dual core
processors on your laptops.
And so the scale, now,
is-- the metric now,
I should say-- is how many
cores do you have on a chip.
And people are
predicting that we're
going to have 1,000
cores by 2020, on a chip.
So this brings us to the problem
of how do we use parallelism.
So there's a lot of work
in parallel algorithms.
And there's also work
in building hardware,
such that algorithms can
sort of automatically
be parallelized while
they're running in hardware,
so they can run faster,
and so on and so forth.
So some of my research is
in parallel architecture.
Some of it is in
parallel algorithms.
I want to give you a sense
of what the problems are
in building parallel
architectures.
And in particular, I'll start
with a canonical system that
corresponds to, let's say,
this quad core system.
And so you have 4 processors on
this single integrated circuit.
So that signifies that.
And typically, you have a lot
of fast, static random-access
memory, SRAM, on the same chip.
So typically,
megabytes of the memory
on the chip and gigabytes
of memory in DRAM,
which are separate
modules that are connected
via high speed
bus, off the chip.
So there are usually
many DRAM modules.
They're called DIMMS-- if you
might have heard the term.
So the connection between
the processors and the SRAM
is typically very fast.
It's on-chip.
Things being clocked
at gigahertz.
And when you go
off-chip, you're down
to a few hundred megahertz.
So typically, an order
of magnitude less speed.
But you're accessing
much more memory.
So this is really
gigabytes and this
is at the level of megabytes.
If you see this
picture, here-- if you
think about the number
of processors increasing
from four to eight to
16, all the way to,
say, to hundreds
of processors, you
can see that there's going
to be a bottleneck associated
with accessing the memory.
The big problem is
you can't possibly
build memory that
serves hundreds
of requests in parallel.
If you try and make a large
SRAM, which is megabytes long,
the number of
ports in the SRAM--
read ports-- is roughly
of the order of four.
And after that it's
kind of hard to build.
So this architecture isn't going
to be sustainable beyond 4, 8,
maybe 16 cores.
So typically, what
people build is--
or people are trying
to build in academia--
is something that corresponds
to a distributed architecture
on the chip, where you have
processors and memory in tiles.
So you have,
essentially, something
like this, where you can
imagine having literally 100
processors on a chip that
correspond to an implementation
where you build tiles, where
you have a processor that's
doing the computation, and
you have memory-- sometimes
called cache memory.
But there's multiple levels
of caches, typically, that
are attached to each
of these processors.
And the space between
the processor tiles
is reserved for
interconnect or for wires
that connect these
processors up.
And so there's research that
goes on in routing algorithms.
How you figure out if
these processors want
to talk to each other; what
the best way of routing
the messages are; you want
to find the shortest path.
In this case, the
weight corresponds
to the congestion
that's associated
with each of these
channels that you have.
And people actually
use algorithms
like weighted shortest
paths, in hardware,
to determine what the best way
of getting from here to there
is.
It may not be this way.
It may be going
around the chip simply
because that path-- the
latter one is less congested.
The other issue
that comes up has
to do with how long it
takes to go across the chip
and come back.
So if this processor wants
to access its local memory--
that's typically
pretty simple or fast.
But if it wants to
access remote memory--
and it's quite
possible that it's
sharing some data with a
different thread running
on a different processor.
So typically, there's
a program running
on this processor,
sometimes called a thread,
and this program may share data
with a different program, which
is running on this processor.
Or it may just require
a lot more space.
And what this program has
to do is make a request
all the way to this processor
and this particular cache
in this processor.
And then it gets the data back.
So what you see here
is a round trip access
that goes across the chip.
And this distance,
if it's large,
could take 10s of cycles.
So typically, it's
a single cycle
to access local memory--
the fastest local memory,
called the L1 cache.
But it could take 10s of
cycles to go send a message
across the chip and 10s of
cycles to get the data back.
So the bottleneck, really,
in parallel processing
from a standpoint
of communication
is this routing of messages
and getting the messages back.
One of the things that my
research group is doing
is looking at the
notion of migrating
computation as opposed to data.
We call it execution
migration, where
you could say-- suppose I
have a processor running
a particular program, out here.
And if this program wanted
to access a remote memory,
then, rather than
doing what I just
showed you there--
send a message,
get the data back--
you could imagine
that you could migrate
the program itself.
And in particular,
you think of it
as migrating the
context of the program
from this processor to this one.
And so what is the context?
For those of you who
have taken 6.004 probably
know what this is.
But it's simply where
you are in terms
of executing your program.
And that's typically
given to you
by our program counter, and your
current state of your register
file, and a few other
things, including
cache memory and
so on and so forth.
So the advantage with
execution migration
is that it's a one way trip,
as opposed to a round trip.
You don't have to send a
message and get the data back,
which would be two
messages, if you will--
one in the case of the
address and the other
for the data-- but you
migrate your execution.
Since you have
computation out here,
you can run on this
remote processor.
So that's one of the advantages
of execution migration
One of the downsides
of it is that this
can be multiple
kilobytes-- or kilobits.
And it could be significantly
more in terms of size,
or in terms of bits, than the
data that you want to access.
So there's a trade-off here.
And then, when any time
you have a trade-off,
you can think of an
algorithm to try and find
the optimal trade-off.
So this is the context for the
particular optimization problem
that we need to solve,
here, that corresponds
to really deciding when you
want to do data migration
and when you want to
do execution migration.
There's a choice.
At the top level, it's a
round trip to get the data.
So you're really traveling
longer-- twice as long.
The distance is twice as much.
But it's possible
that the amount
of state that
you'd have to move,
in terms of taking your
context of your thread
and moving across the
chip, could be large enough
that it offsets the advantage
of the shorter distance.
So we set this up as an
optimization problem.
So now we're in the realm of--
we moved from 6.004 to 6.006,
here, in the last
couple of seconds.
So assume we know or
can predict the access
pattern of a program.
And you can do
this-- people build
these things in hardware--
prefetch engines,
branch predictors, and so on.
They're in the x86 machines.
And you can tell-- especially
if you're going through a loop
over and over-- you can
make this prediction.
So you have some
amount of look ahead.
And you know that
m1 through mn are
the memory accesses that this
program is going to make.
And these other
memory addresses.
And I'm going to think about
p of m1, p of m2, p of mn,
as the processor
caches for each mi.
So what might be the
case, in a simple example,
is you want to access
memory in processor one.
You're sitting
there and you want
to access memory
in processor one.
And then, the next one,
you want to access memory
in processor two.
And so on and so forth.
So you might see
something like that.
So the sequence of
memory addressees--
if you're sitting on processor
one-- this first one is local.
And then, after that, you
want to access processor two's
memory because you're
sharing data with it.
Then you're back home,
again, to processor one.
And so on and so forth.
So that's one
example of a set up.
And we can think of about
the cost of migration
as-- if you want
to go from s to d--
as being a function
of the distance,
s comma d, plus
some constant, which
is proportional to
the context size.
And that context size,
we're going to assume
is fixed for a
particular architecture.
It may change for
different architectures,
but if it's a few
kilobits, then there's
going to be some
overhead associated
with putting the context
onto the network.
And it's a sizable overhead that
needs to be taken into account.
That's the cost of migration.
The cost of an
access, s comma d,
is twice the distance
between s and d.
And it's typically
just a word that you
want to access--
32 bits, 64 bits--
and so there's no additional
overhead associated with a data
access.
So there you go.
You have the formulation
of the problem.
You have the trade-off written,
where the cost of migration
has just the distance.
But it has a constant factor.
And you've got twice the
distance, here, for the access.
Now if s equals d, and I
want to write this down,
you have a local access.
And the cost is
assumed to be zero.
You could change that.
We are in the realm of
the theory and symbols.
So you can do whatever you want.
But given those
equations, our problem
is decide when to migrate to
minimize total memory access
cost.
So in our example
there, I suppose
we had p1, p2, p2, et cetera.
And let's say you start at p1.
This first one would
be a local access.
And then, you may
decide that you
want to migrate
to p2, over here.
In this case, you get this
as a local access, as well.
So is this one.
Right here, you might want to
migrate to p1 back to be p1.
So this becomes a local access.
That's a local access.
They're all, essentially, free.
And then, if you
just stay at p1,
over here, you may end up doing
remote accesses to p3 and p2,
respectively.
And so you have a cost
of migration-- the cost
of migration and the cost
of two remote access.
So that's the set up.
How are we going to
solve this problem?
Are we going Dijkstra?
Are we going to
use Bellman-Ford?
Are we going to use
balanced search trees?
Are we going to
use hash functions?
What are we going to use?
AUDIENCE: Dynamic Programming.
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS:
Dynamic Programming.
All together.
EVERYONE: Dynamic Programming.
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS:
Dynamic programming, all right.
We're going to use
dynamic programming
to solve this problem.
Good.
So Erik taught you something.
AUDIENCE: Where are the erasers?
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah.
Where are the erasers?
I think they
fluttered down here.
All right.
Let me bail out and use this
while you find the erasers.
So a program at p1, which
is the processor, initially.
I'm just going to
set up this DP.
Let's assume that the number
of processors equals Q. Now,
what are the subproblems?
You could do this
many different ways.
Let's go ahead and use prefixes.
And so DP(k,p1) is the cost
of the optimal solution
for the prefix m1 through
mk of memory accesses,
when the program starts
at p1 and ends at pi.
So that's my subproblem.
I want to know, as
I build this up,
what is the optimal
way that I'm going
to choose between
migrations and accesses
for the first k memory access,
assuming a starting point at p1
and ending at some pi.
And I need to build
up these subproblems.
And I want to grow them.
Let's go ahead and set this up.
What I want to do now is
figure out DP(k plus 1, pj).
And assuming I have all
of the k, pi's computed--
and how many
subproblems do I have?
How many subproblems do I have?
Total?
Look at this and tell me what
the ranges of the possibilities
are.
So how many subproblems
would I have?
Someone?
N times Q. So you have
N times Q subproblems.
So you've set this up for
up until k and for all
of the pi's.
Now, what you have to do
is essentially say, well,
DP of k plus 1, pj is going to
be k, pj plus cost of access
pj, p of mk plus 1 if pj is
not equal to p of mk plus 1.
So there's going
to be two cases.
I'll just write this
out and I'll explain it.
But the first case corresponds
to if the new memory
access is not in the processor
cache corresponding to pj,
then what you could do
is use the optimum value,
where you ended pj, and
simply do a remote access that
corresponds to
accessing mk plus 1.
So that's one case.
The case is to use the minimum
solution-- optimum solution
corresponding to ending
at pi and do a migration.
You have cost of
migration from pi to pj.
And you do this if you
want to go do p of mk
plus 1-- the processor
corresponding to p
of mk plus 1.
So that's the set up for
this dynamic program.
What you've done is created
a sub problem, its optimum,
and then you look
at the two cases.
You want to go migrate and
do a local access-- that's
this case over here.
Migrate to the processor
and do a local access there.
That will be this case.
And in this case, you stay where
you are and do a remote access.
In the case of migration, you
could end up choosing different
initial starting points
corresponding to the pi's.
And you have to run
through all of those.
So what's the cost of a
subproblem, or the running time
of computing one of these
things-- it's order?
Q. And so the total
cost is NQ squared.
It's a little review of DP.
I'm going to stop here
and let Erik take over.
Just, in closing, while
this makes some assumptions,
It's actually
fairly close to what
we're building in hardware.
This type of
analysis is something
that we have to do in hardware.
My research group is building
a 128 processor machine,
that we call the Execution
Migration Machine.
And it does exactly what
I've described to you,
decide whether to
do a remote access
or to do a migration based
on this kind of analysis.
So hand it over to Erik.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE:
I have a microphone.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: All right.
Good.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE:
So I have a few things
to tell you a little bit about.
Srini talked about
one topic in detail.
I'm going to talk about
many topics in less detail,
as I said "shallowly."
And these are my main
areas of research.
I do geometry, in particular,
folding, and data structures,
graphs, and
recreational algorithms.
That's the really fun stuff.
A lot of these have
corresponding courses
if you're interested in
more about this stuff.
Computational
geometry, in general,
is-- I'm not going to
remember all numbers.
840?
50?
50.
6.850.
That's a class I don't teach.
Folding is 6.849.
Data Structures is 6.851.
And Graphs was being
taught this semester,
in parallel with this class.
6.889.
And recreational algorithms
isn't fully covered
but you could check
out SP.268, which
was offered last semester.
And especially for
those watching at home
on MIT OpenCourseWare--
this class,
all the video lectures
are online for free.
6.851, we'll do
that next semester.
And 6.889 are all
online, right now.
And there's some lecture notes
for SP.268 on OpenCourseWare.
There's a lot of material, here.
And in particular, the obvious
next class for you to be taking
is 6.046.
But why should you
be taking 6.046?
Because then you can take
all these exciting classes
and many others
about algorithms.
There's a complete list
of follow-on classes
in the lecture notes,
which are online.
And there's a ton of-- there's
so much research in algorithms.
It's a really exciting area.
This is just the
beginning-- just a taste.
And I want to show you various
exciting places it can go.
Let's do some algorithms.
So the first topic I'll
tell you a little bit
about-- maybe the most fun-- is
geometric folding algorithms.
That's the title of the
textbook and the class 6.849.
And in general--
well, there's a lot
of different kinds of
folding, in the world,
but maybe the most accessible
and fun is origami.
So you have, on the one
hand, a piece of paper.
And you'd like to turn it into
some crazy, three dimensional
shape, which I'm not
going to try to draw here.
You want to fold
a giraffe or you
want to make some
geometric sculpture.
How do you do this?
So, usually, you put some
creases into the piece of paper
in some reasonable way.
And one of the
questions is what are
the rules for putting creases
into a piece of paper?
When is that possible?
And then you'd like to
fold it into that shape.
So there are really
two big problems here.
One is I guess you could
call it foldability.
And this is what you do
if you practice origami
in the typical way.
You get origami diagrams,
and they say, "fold this."
And you're like, oh, gosh.
Takes you hours to figure
out how to fold something.
Especially, if they just
gave you a crease pattern.
Can you even tell does it fold
into anything, first of all.
And then, if so, how do I do it?
That problem-- folding increase
pattern and understanding
what crease patterns are valid--
unfortunately, is NP-complete.
So there's no good way to
really understand that.
So origami is hard.
In some sense, the more
interesting direction,
though, is the
reverse direction,
which I would call
origami design.
I have an intended 3D
shape I want to design.
How can I come up with-- how
can I, as an algorithm, convert
that 3D shape into a crease
pattern that does fold,
that's guaranteed to
fold into that 3D shape.
And that's actually solvable.
So design is easier.
And there's all sorts
of different versions
of the design problem.
Some of them, you could
solve in polynomial time.
Some of them, you can't.
If you really want
optimal design,
that can be NP-complete again.
But in particular, there's a way
to fold any 3D shape you want.
So there's an algorithm--
the coolest one, right now,
is called Origamizer.
It's free software
online, by Tomohiro Tachi.
And you give it a 3D
model of a polyhedron.
And it outputs a
giant crease pattern
on a square piece of paper that
folds into that 3D polyhedron.
And it's reasonably practical.
And he's folded tons
of models in that way.
Let's see.
I'll show you some other things.
Here's a simple example of
a geometric origami model.
So this is folded from a square
paper with concentric squares
as creases.
Alternating mountain and valley.
So you see mountain
valley, mountain valley.
Also fold the diagonals.
It's very easy to make.
And what's funny--
what's cool about it
is that when you put
all those creases in,
it pops into this 3D shape,
which for many years people
conjectured was a
hyperbolic parabola.
This design is one of the
earliest geometric origami
designs.
It goes back to late '20s in
the Bauhaus School of Design.
And it's very cool.
People fold them a lot.
I've personally folded
thousands of them
for sculpture and things.
We also do a lot of
algorithmic sculpture, which
I won't talk about
in detail here.
But we discovered, two years
ago, that this does not exist.
It is impossible to fold
a square piece of paper
with this crease pattern.
That was a bit of a surprise.
And it's kind of fun to make
things that don't exist.
AUDIENCE: So what is that?
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE:
So what is this?
Well, somehow, physical world is
differing from the real world.
Now, some ways it
might be differing
are that these
creases might not be
creases in the technical sense.
A crease is a place that
should be non-differentiable.
So maybe they're kind
of rounding it out.
And then, who knows
what's happening.
Then, kind of all bets are off.
Another possibility of
what I think is happening
is that their are extra creases,
in here, that you don't see.
They're very small.
If you look, especially the raw
edge, here, and that profile.
It's a little bit wavy.
And it's conceivable
there's some points here
that look
non-differentiable to me.
And I always thought I wasn't
folding it well enough.
But in fact, something
like that has to happen.
And my conjecture
is, if you look
at this under a microscope,
which we haven't done yet,
there are little creases
that are so shallow they're
hard to see, but are there.
And the theorem says some
creases have to be there.
It is possible to fold
this with extra creases,
but not with these.
So get rid of that.
On the other hand, if
you do the same thing
with concentric circular
creases-- this a little harder
to unfold.
It really wants to be in
this kind of Pringles shape.
This also is from about Bauhaus.
It's a little harder to
fold concentric circles.
But this, we think, does exist.
Can't prove it yet.
So we've done a lot of
sculpture based on these guys.
What else do I want to say?
Another demo.
So here's a fun problem.
This is a magic trick.
Goes back to Houdini and others.
So imagine I take a rectangle
of paper and then I fold it flat
and take my scissors--
not strict origami, here--
and I make one
complete straight cut.
In this case, I get two pieces.
And I unfold the pieces.
And the question is what shapes
can I get out of those pieces?
In this case, I get a swan.
You're not impressed
so I'll another one.
Make one straight cut.
These are on my web
page if you want
to impress all your friends.
You could take the class if
you want to know how it's done.
This example has
a lot of symmetry.
You get a little angelfish.
I only have one more example.
I hope you'll be impressed.
This is very hard to fold.
It was an MIT spotlight
picture, at some point.
And it's even harder to cut.
Straight cut.
This should be the MIT logo.
[APPLAUSE]
So the theorem is there's
an algorithm, given
any set of polygons
in the plane,
you could fold, make
one straight cut,
and get exactly those polygons.
There's some
limits, in practice,
because of paper thickness.
But in theory, you
can do everything.
All right.
Fun stuff.
I don't think I have time
to talk about self-assembly.
Let me talk a little bit
about data structures because,
conveniently, Srini drew
this diagram for me.
And I have the exact same
diagram-- the left one, though.
I'm old fashioned.
So the models of computation
we've used, in this class,
are pretty simple.
We have, in particular,
the Word RAM.
You can read a word.
You can add two words.
Do whatever you want with
a constant number words.
Send them out to main memory.
Everything's the
same amount of time.
It's all constant,
anyway, so who cares?
Except there's this
issue in real computers,
and it gets even worse
with parallel, but let's
stick to sequential old
fashioned computers.
So you have this slow bottleneck
between main memory and cache.
Cache is really fast.
Think of this as
a really fat pipe.
And this is a very thin pipe.
What do we do?
We'd like to always work
with things in cache,
but that's kind of difficult.
At some point, you
run out of space.
You've got to go to main memory.
And maybe to disc, other
levels of the memory hierarchy.
So what systems do is, when you
fetch something from memory,
you don't just get one word,
you get an entire cache line.
And cache lines are
getting bigger and bigger.
But memory transfers
happen in blocks,
when you're going
to a big memory.
So let's say B is
the size of a block.
There is another
model of computation
that's more sophisticated
than the Word RAM that
says how should my running time
depend on B. How many memory
transfers do I need to do,
as a function of B and n?
And so for example, if you
want to do search-- normally,
we think of doing binary search.
That takes log(n) accesses
if everything is uniform.
But with asymmetry,
and if you're
reading in entire blocks,
if you do it right,
you can do it in log base B
of n, instead of log base 2.
This is counting memory
transfers, not computation.
Computation here is free.
It's a little weird,
but you get used to it.
Sorting.
They're classic.
Just to give you an idea of how
this gets a little complicated.
You get n divided by B times
log base C of n divided by B. C
is the number of blocks
that fit in here.
So there's C different blocks
that fit in your cache.
That's the optimal way to sort.
Just upper and lower bounds
in the comparison model.
Just to give you a flavor.
And there's a whole study
of algorithms to do this.
What's really cool is you
can achieve these bounds
even if you don't
know what B is.
And if you don't know what C is.
There's one algorithm, that
whatever the architecture is
underlying it, we'll still
achieve the same bounds.
Those are called
cache-oblivious algorithms,
and they were
invented, here, at MIT.
I think I want to-- this
is too much fun to pass up.
On the Word RAM,
there's this problem,
which we've dealt
with several times.
What if you want to maintain
a dynamic set of elements--
integers.
I want to do insert, delete,
predecessor, successor.
This is what binary
search trees do.
But you can do better.
If we have integers-- n
integers-- in the range
0 to u minus 1.
So u is the size
of the universe.
Then, we already know
how to do log(n).
But you can do two bounds.
One is log(log(u)).
This is a data structure
called [INAUDIBLE].
And it's in CLRS, if
you're interested.
You can also do log(log(n))
divided by log(log(u)).
This is a data structure
called fusion trees.
It's an advanced data structure.
6.851, if you're interested.
And you can take the
min of those two.
That's, essentially,
the best possible,
the matching lower
bound, that that that's
all you can achieve.
And so just to state it
in terms that you know,
which is normal n bounds.
You take the min of
those two things,
there are always at most
square root log(n) divided
by log(log(n)).
Compare that with log(n).
It's way better.
A whole square root better.
And a little tiny
savings better.
And this is optimal.
It is a function of n.
That's the best you can do
for the predecessor problem.
So pretty crazy stuff.
It's a very
complicated structure.
It's probably
completely impractical.
But, hey.
They're, theoretically,
pretty cool.
I'll tell you a little bit
about graph algorithms.
We've seen a lot of graph
algorithms in this class.
One way to make them new and fun
again is to suppose your graph
is planar or almost planer.
Meaning you can draw
it in two dimensions
without any crossings, as you
might get from a graph that's
drawn on the earth,
like a road network
or something with no
or few overpasses.
Then you can do
things a lot better.
For example, you can
do the equivalent
of Dijkstra's algorithm.
So non-negative weight
shortest path, in linear time.
That's not so impressive cause
Dijkstra is number of edges.
Here, I mean number of vertices.
It doesn't really matter
with planar graphs.
And we had E log(V).
You can write E,
here, if you prefer.
It's only a log savings.
More impressive, is you can
do with negative weights--
the equivalent of Bellman-Ford--
in almost linear time.
So some log factors.
Log squared n divided
by log(log(n)).
It's the best bound
known to date.
That was a result
from last year.
So it's still a
work in progress.
And if you're interested
in this kind of stuff,
you should check out the videos
for the class we just taught,
6.889.
And recreation algorithms.
I've actually already
told you about a lot
of these-- like algorithms for
solving a Rubik's cube in n
squared divided by log(n) steps.
That was a paper this year.
Tetris is NP-complete.
A whole bunch of
NP-completeness, and x time
completeness, and so on.
Results for games.
Other fun stuff, like
balloon twisting-- algorithms
for designing how to balloon
twist a given polyhedron,
optimally, using
the fewest balloons.
Algorithmic magic tricks.
There's tons of stuff out there.
It's really fun.
I should teach a class
about some of those things,
but I haven't yet.
The last thing we wanted
to do is together.
And it has to do with these
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS:
Getting rid of these--
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE:
These cushions.
Getting rid of
these damn cushions.
We have so many
of these cushions.
Just gotta get rid of them.
That's two freebies.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Now, you're
going to have to pay
for these cushions.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: He's kidding.
He's kidding.
Actually we're having trouble.
We're having trouble
giving them away
because-- I don't
know-- some people seem
to not like them very much.
And neither do we.
So we wanted to give you some
motivation for why you really
need some of these cushions.
So we actually
prepared a top 10 list.
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS:
This is the top 10
uses of 6.006 cushions.
We're going to alternate here.
Number 10.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE:
You can sit on it
and get guaranteed
inspiration in constant time.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Don't forget
to bring one for the final exam.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE:
Highly recommended it.
Number nine.
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS:
You can use it as a Frisbee.
You've seen that before, except
you cut it into a circle.
You cut it into a circle.
And it works really well.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE: We had
fun with a Bandsaw, last night.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Number eight.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE:
You can sell it
as a limited edition
collectible on eBay.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: It's never
ever going to be made, again.
You can make money off
this in 5 years-- 10 years.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: At least $5.
I don't know.
Number seven.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Number seven.
If you had two of these, you
could stick them like this,
and remove the branding, and
use it as a regular cushion.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: Now, no one
will ever know you
took this class.
You just need two.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Number six.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: Number six.
It's a holiday
conversation starter.
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS:
And conversation stopper.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: Number five.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Asymptotically
optimal-- we had
to use that term,
acoustic acoustic paneling.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE: That
was a suggestion from a student.
You just need a lot of them.
This would be great for piano,
guitar fingering practice.
You know you're doing your DP.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Number four.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: Number four.
You can use it as target
practice for your next larp
session.
Woah.
Misfire.
I'm missing.
PROFESSOR SRINI DEVADAS:
You haven't hit me yet.
All right.
Finally, you got one.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: Number three.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: All right.
10 years from now,
it might be all
you remember about double 0 6.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: In truth, you
might also remember
this top 10 list.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: All right.
Number two.
PROFESSOR ERIK
DEMAINE: Number two.
You can use it as your
final exam cheat sheet.
This is a new rule.
Instead of 8 and
1/2 by 11, you could
bring in the appropriate
number of cushions.
And the number one-- number one
use for a double 0 6 cushion.
PROFESSOR SRINI
DEVADAS: Three words.
OK Cupid profile picture.
Don't use this cheat sheet.
But come to the final
exam and good luck.
PROFESSOR ERIK DEMAINE: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]